alright good afternoon everybody so the
title of my talk is how mobile disrupt
social as we know it so what is social
as we know it hmm how many people are on
Facebook maybe I should ask how many
people are not on Facebook all right so
you now so you all know social as we
know it okay you know what that means so
let me put on a computer science hat and
i would say that from a computer science
perspective the way we build these
social networks these days is a little
bit sad and embarrassing because what we
have today are these centralized cloud
services in order for you to share you
sign up and you say here is my data
facebook or any other social network
please take my data and share it for me
okay so this is these are centralized
services the computer science
researchers have spent lots of time on
distributed computing so people can own
their different data and then they can
share from different sources but somehow
that's not the kind of systems we have
today so we have all these centralized
services and these are what we call
social intranet as opposed to social
internets what are social intranet you
know when you say if you sign up to work
for a company you fill out the form and
then you say look all my intellectual
property belongs to the company and
that's called the intranet in a sense of
the material is available if your
employee inside the company but to some
extent these social networks that we
have today are intranets because there
is a long EULA how many people read the
EULA oh my you know what the ulus says
right i mean they own the data you can
do whatever they wish with it and by the
way it doesn't really matter if you read
it or not because they can they reserve
the right to change the EULA anytime so
but anyway there are such thing as
social Internet have we seen any social
internets before do you think anybody
could there be such a thing actually
you've been using both two very famous
social internets one is email all right
because with email you can pick the
provider of the email service and you
can interoperate with each other there
are three Giants for the consumer email
services there's hotmail gmail and yahoo
mail I mean these are the huge Giants
they may you know they they provide you
a free service they may monetize the
data but you have a choice and at the
same time universities can pick up and
can put up their own companies can put
up their own individuals can even put up
their own and you have a choice between
paid and free services and they all
interoperate and that's called social
internet another example the social
Internet is a telephone system because I
may be on verizon and you may be on AT&T
we can still talk to each other we don't
have to say you have to join the same
network before I can call you okay so
these are social internets but with
these centralized services we have we
have these proprietary systems we have
these proprietary social networks today
from this proprietary social networks we
have these proprietary at platforms how
many people have heard of farmville
sorry farmville is hot is very very
successful it is a it's a solution it's
a game from zynga and by the by using
the Facebook network they grew really
really quickly and they're so when when
these when a social network like
Facebook puts out these are platforms it
is very very attractive to a lot of
companies you know so for that they do
have to pay and some you know before
they IPO they Facebook terms then they
say oh for the service you have to give
us thirty percent of your revenues okay
what is thirty percent of the revenues
it turns up for that quarter I'm I don't
know if you can see it they reported
like a drop of ninety-five percent of
their profits
okay that is pretty steep because these
are revenues and not just profits is
that a fair number possibly all right I
mean they really owed it to Facebook in
a sense to get that big really quickly
so that may be a fair number what is the
right number anyway well it really
depends on the market usually the market
determines the number what if what if a
social network turns around says I
really want sixty percent is that fair
well it really depends on whether there
is a market or whether there is a choice
if Zynga doesn't want to go with
Facebook do they have a choice to go to
and whether there's a choice determines
the money determines the price if there
is an open market but if you don't have
an open market if we for example have a
monopoly then it would be controlled by
a single company okay so it's a little
bit concerning for some of us and then
from the proprietary I platform lately
we have seen another thing that's
happening is the messaging systems there
is a in 2011 it was reported that the
the operators lost like 14 billion
dollars in SMS revenues and people are
moving towards these over-the-top
messaging services and there was an
article I thought that was a really
interesting one from TechCrunch saying
that there is a message war going and
they think it is going to be Apple
Google or Facebook going after that so
messaging is something that we
understood to be open in the past and it
looks like there is a chance for
messaging to become proprietary and
closed and these come there are
companies traditionally who'd say we
provide these for free services and we
are expect you know we will basically
promise that they will monetize your
data and do something with that data and
so if you ads and so forth so the
question really here is that we started
with social networking that didn't exist
before and then we kind of the
proprietary nature of these concerns
have kind of got into the app platform
and now we may be seeing the
app the messaging going that direction
as well so there are various people who
are concerned about that and in 2010
there is a group of New York University
students and they started this this this
movement they said we're going to build
an open and distributed Facebook
equivalent it's called diaspora how many
people have heard of diaspora they got
pretty famous they announced it and a
lot of people supported them but
unfortunately it didn't really work out
we waited for it and it didn't quite
work out and as a matter of fact when
they announced it in 2010 our research
group which started in 2008 on mobile
and social has already started a project
similar to that with a little bit more
research elements in it and we were
closing that project down by then the
reason we realize is that it's just not
going to work why a couple of reasons
right number think one thing is it if
you really want you have a social
network you have to interrupt great
across people who care about privacy and
who people who don't care about privacy
if you just make a network that is good
for people who do care about privacy
it's a very small Network and it's also
a very a social network because they
care so much about privacy so the first
thing that we learn from that is from
that experience is that it has to op
interoperate between the free and the
paid and then you get a chance so that's
rule number one rule number two is that
you just cannot say let me just first of
all people don't care that much of our
privacy let me just give mikis make a
social network that's kind of like
Facebook except that I we are new so
we're going to give you a fraction of
what facebook already offers and expect
people to come that's not gonna happen
you know what they're already a billion
people and Facebook they said it is
plenty Phi there is no need for another
system that is a subset of that
experience so what it says to us is that
if they want to do anything about this
you have to create a new
and draw people to the new experience
instead of just saying that you care
about privacy so those are the lessons
that we learned so how do we do this
this is a really hard problem a lot of
people there's a lot of money behind all
this is a really hard problem and we
worked on it since 2008 and we realize
that mobile may give us a chance because
this is the new revolution in Computer
History this is a big one we went from
mainframe to pcs and we say now we have
all these opportunities to do to control
our own computing resources that was
great and then we realize is that but my
pieces are heavy my laptops are heavy I
don't really want to I couldn't get
access to my data everywhere so we'd
like it in the cloud all right so we
kind of swing the pendulum kind of swing
back and say let's store everything in
the cloud in the meantime the technology
got good enough that we can store all
kinds of things in the cloud but this
round we got these phones quad-core per
phone gigabytes of storage per person
and now the phones are going to reach
the entire world okay because of with
Moore's law you just have to wait a
little bit all the dumb phones are going
to be smart and it's going to reach
every single person and this is a chance
for us to swing back from the cloud
services to a more distributed service
where you have control over your own
device now the thing about mobile is it
is actually better than these
centralized cloud services why because
it's more available ok even when i'm on
my plane all my photos are available on
my on the plane and by the way when I go
to bed I put it down it's my alarm clock
and it can even wake me up if there is a
reason for this to do so ok so this is
Ellen of course you know you have signed
in to all your networks and all your
accounts it is faster than you to go to
any other terminal and to do any
transaction so it really is you it is
your personality
and so in that sense it is a very
special place you know in those old days
when we say personal computer the reason
we have to add personal to it is because
it is not so personal we have nobody
talks about the personal phone but this
is truly the personal phone you don't
have to qualify them phone to say this
is the personal phone now the other
thing is that the phone actually has the
largest social network why did I say
that alright if you take Stanford I'd
say 99.99 percent of all the students
are on Facebook guess what they are not
my friends would you friend me sure it's
inappropriate for you know there are
schools that tell teachers not to friend
their students it's an appropriate there
is personal life work live school life
the fact that you are all on that
doesn't make doesn't give me the big
social networks but on the other hand
what is interesting is it because I'm
over because I'm on Stanford I can go to
the stanford directory i can actually
reach everybody here because i have
access to all your email addresses see
so i have access to all the students
acts addresses all my colleagues if
there is a reason for me to reach them i
can reach them by virtue of me being a
part of stanford the fact that you are
all on facebook doesn't really make my
network bigger so there's concept here
is that if you look at what is on the
phone I have access to all my Facebook
friends all my Stanford colleagues and
students and LinkedIn and all the other
social networks so as far as I am
concerned this phone has a bigger social
network than the network out there all
right so that is an interesting
observation that if you look at look at
what is on the phone year it has access
to all the different social networks as
well as you know this is with me you
have a phone with you and I should be
able to contact contact you connect with
you as well so that's the background so
here is the architecture that we have
come up with the funny thing is that it
took us this is our fourth try we
throw away three different systems to
come up with this architecture it's very
very simple and only simple things works
by the simple things work by the way so
what does this say is this look today
the way we connected to our friends is
through these huge social networks like
Facebook LinkedIn and what have you and
each one of these networks has this own
set of rules these are the social rules
of engagement we know what it means to
be friends or friends on Facebook okay
for you to friend me you know that
you're going to give me access to a lot
of things than just you do some you know
play a game together on using facebook
connect all right so there are lots of
rules associated with facebook or face
or LinkedIn and so forth however if I
look at the phone is like the phones are
so powerful why are they why are we
treating them like they are little
little thin client attached to the cloud
all right why is it that I can go and
talk to you directly you have your phone
I have a phone you know why do I need a
third party storing or keeping track of
our relationships and following us so
why is it and one of the biggest problem
with these phones is that they route
using TCP IP address what is your TCP IP
address I don't even know my TCP IP
address let alone your TCP IP address so
what we have created is a very simple
messaging core infrastructure and what
it does is that it allows people to
exchange messages based on their
existing identities what are they email
phone numbers Facebook numbers all right
please and and as long as I know you
there is some kind of a name identity I
should be able to connect with you via
this messaging service so we are now
going back to more like a contact book
model and when I do something with you
all you get is what I'm doing with you
don't get all the friends of friends and
pictures that I'm sharing and other
networks it is just that straight up you
know that is the connection we do
something together and that's the end of
that so that's the basic idea is that
now that if I can connect with you
personally
then I can do all kinds of things with
you and one thing we do is to make that
messaging experient messaging function
available to the apps okay oh by the way
I should mention that when I say that
there is a messaging system sometimes my
phone is offline so it is necessary for
the messaging Corps to hold on to the
data until it is distributed until it is
retrieved okay but once it gives it has
you over the data it can go ahead and
and delete it because it is only a
messenger so what we've done is then
make this messaging layer of available
to the apps so for example if you're
playing a little Scrabble game between
three people the Scrabble game can just
run straight on those phones you know is
that I play the word hello on Row two
column three it's just a little bit of a
message it just goes under the network
and deliver to those two phones the
three of us are in a little scrapbook
you know Scrabble social network
together instant for a short little
while and there is nothing more to it
than that so now we can enable all kinds
of multi-party interactions built on top
of this simple messaging Corps and then
you'd say to me is like what I mean were
what happened to the data what happened
if I lose my phone well you know you
have a lot of valuable stuff on your
phone already it's called the gallery
what do you do with a gallery you back
it up okay maybe you use Dropbox maybe
you pack pack it up to your pc and so
forth so what we are asking to do then
is that you have your phone back up all
the communicator data can also be back
up and you can choose the you know
choose the backup of your choice you can
put it in G Drive I can put it in a
scribe drop drive you can put in two
different accounts of the dropbox and
now we are sharing across these
resources together these servers in the
cloud there are a lot of free services
in the cloud or you can pay for some of
these services and it is you know and it
is all to you but now we can interact
with each other so that's the basic idea
behind this messaging system this
architecture and let's go back to this
big picture
remember we are saying how we go from
the social network to the app platform
from the app platform people I provide
are getting into the proprietary
messaging what we are doing now is to
stay so let's start with the open
messaging make the messaging available
to the apps then we can open up the app
platform and from the app platform you
can go store your data anywhere you want
and that's open up the social network
all right so this is the direction that
we discovered you know guess what what
happened when we try to do this research
in 2008 the first thing we did was to
try to compete ends like oh let's build
this open social network like the
Diaspora thing was like that just
doesn't work we retreated ms al let's
work on this that doesn't work and
finally we found that there is a
possibility because we have nailed it to
the very small core then we can
potentially provide and now you can grow
it back out in an open way so that's the
big like that basic idea now what I have
been talking to you about a very
important issues privacy monopoly and
scalability scalability refers to the
fact that they're going to be gazillion
billions of phones out there we all
going around taking videos of dogs and
cats and sharing them do you really
really think that there should be one
centralized service that holds all the
data so that these videos can be shared
between people do we really believe in
that I don't I believe that this is a
disruption in the computer technology
space the phones are very different from
the PCs we will see a lot more
distributed computing and so that's why
scalability is up there do you guys care
about these things yeah how many people
care about these things all right well
the funny thing is that I when I you
know we've been teaching this mobile and
social class and every year I would ask
my students and most of the students
don't just don't care they just don't
care it took me four years for them to
teach me they really mean it when they
say they don't care I said you really
care a little bit
right if I give you a choice just take
facebook as it is and Facebook with some
guarantee on privacy exactly the same
will you take the one with a privacy
guarantee and they say no and what we
hear here is that you know it we're very
concerned so what do we do so what I
have described to you if you're a
computer science person you realize that
i'm talking about a distributed
operating system and file system there
are tons of things that we spent many
many years on and we have built various
systems some of you may have heard of a
KFSN coda none of these things ever
lived to be used by the consumers right
because why because a lot of the systems
professors I'm one of those they don't
think about going cross-platform going
adopt being adoptable usability
programmability okay and and more
importantly you really have to get give
people a better experience all right
don't just say this is good for you just
believe me it's good for you do this you
have to give them a better experience so
what that means is that we pretty much
have to start all over again okay I just
gave you a talk for people that care and
now I have to keep we outgrow really
have to think again all over again it's
like how do we give them an experience
where they say oh that I like that
experience oh good it has got more
better privacy and all that oh that
thank you I don't mind that I suppose
that's how hard this problem this so now
when it's not another talk okay and that
is how do you actually build a better
mobile social experience are we doing
well on social well we definitely have
done on you know in the virtual space we
definitely have done a lot more a lot
better than before but how good are we
okay so there are people who feel like
the social as we know it you know with
Facebook it off
is a gateway for hundreds of shallow
relationships and emotionally detached
communications there are people who
think that the more time you spend on
Facebook the less happy you are I don't
know whether it is cause and effect but
the Facebook model is one where you
broadcast you say this is what I'm doing
and maybe you listen to me but there is
not a lot of back and forth the best I
can do is to give you a like I can give
you a comment I can't really kind of
interact with you socially it is much
more of a broadcast model rather than
interacting model so we thought about it
and we say maybe it's time I mean of
course on facebook you can also choose
to share only with local groups and
small groups and so forth but they don't
make it particularly easy either and the
kind and so so so what we are saying
here is that let's see if we can build
something that is genuine that is for
your general genuine social
relationships we have groups we do have
groups there are big group small groups
there are persistent groups like family
on the spot groups like here I have a
scroop of people here that I'm talking
to you're spending an hour with me okay
we are we're friends were an hour and we
want to be able to interact and there
should be no strings attached I don't
have to sign you don't have to make me a
facebook friend before we can interact
and with the mobile device we should do
a lot more real-time and I I kind of
felt like under mobile device there are
so many creative and collaborate and
creative experiences on these phones and
can we make that available so that
people can be more collaborative and
creative at the same time instead of
just you know talking about what happens
in the morning and so forth so the
question here is can we can we kind of
create a in experience that is more
group oriented we call this micro social
your micro sociology we're interacting
with groups of people real-time creative
and collaborative
that sound interesting to you guys yeah
oh good haha alright so how do we make
this happen you've heard of
collaborative software before great but
usually it's a pain in the neck all
right let me just talk about WebEx
that's tiny little experience to share
some slides and it's pain in the neck
just set up and when we talk about
collaboration in a social setting that
it is much tougher it has to be totally
frictionless so I coined this term it's
afap as frictionless as possible and
computer science people we always have
metrics and the metric that we use here
is the number of human synchronizations
for me to play a game with you what do I
have to do could you please download
that game we're not going to tell you
that I can't call you to tell you that
it's an appropriate it's just a game so
I have to wait for the time when it is
appropriate for me to see you I don't
have anything else to say so why don't
you download that game and then you say
okay I'll do it later and then some time
later you download that game and then
you say okay what is the name that you
use in that game is that how do i play
with you it goes on because the number
of times I have to interact with you
Anna so we have to count the number of
interactions so let's talk about
friction have you seen have you done
this before a group of friends go out or
oh you have a reunion people you don't
see too often and so could you please
take a picture and then you hand over to
the waiter five picture 5 cameras and
they take exactly exactly the same
pictures like why you have a phone I of
a fall I'm going to take a picture of
you guys
and you guys you know I should be able
to just say I just took a picture and
you should get that picture right there
and by the way don't call people say to
me is like of course you have to give up
your data because it is free I don't
know about you I pay about 100 100
dollars a month for this data plan okay
don't tell me that we have to give up
our data for free the company I mean the
phone should allow us to be able to say
I just took a picture you should be able
to get this picture all right commercial
time if you download this app from the
app if you have an iPhone download this
app on the iPhone store and you will see
your pictures if you just go to this
thing that says nearby and you will see
the pictures and you can get the
pictures and right here right then this
is a this is a beta a tech preview that
is put up by my read my research group
have spun out of Stanford they started
this company called Moby social Inc not
particularly creative here and if you
download this app you will see the
spectra and I just exchanged it to you
with you and if you and by the way if
you take a picture of me I get it to you
know I don't usually get pictures of
myself lecturing so pleased that put
some pictures in there I would have
enjoyed that as a matter of fact the
this is what I what we found when we
talk to these some 16 year old girls and
then she said when we go to a high
school dance everybody's dressed up we
want our pictures taken but
unfortunately I can totally take
pictures of other people and people take
pictures of me and I will have to wait
for my friends they upload the pictures
to facebook but who knows what pictures
your friends would maybe uploading maybe
they are too lazy maybe they are not a
big friend of yours maybe they don't
blow your picture you will never get it
so that's the reason why everybody hands
the picture to this to the waiter or to
somebody like please take a picture of
the group with us but now here I have
just made it possible for everybody to
exchange pictures just like that and
it's on your phone immediately so that's
an example of friction
that we can eliminate because we have
phones in it is with us so let's um talk
a little bit of technology here so how
do we really minate friction if you look
at pcs we have files that we have
directories and sharing is kind of like
an afterthought it's like if for me to
share something with you on dropbox i
create a directory and then i put
pictures into that directory and now I
share it do you want to do that on the
phone that doesn't seem right if you
look at the other option is the web web
apps what do you do with web apps you
will go to one app and you put the
pictures up there and everybody joined
there if you go to run another app you
have to go to another you know you will
have to sign in and all these data are
siloed in all the different places so if
you ask me where the pictures are is
like it could be here it could be there
it could be anywhere and what we're
doing here is that when it comes to
mobile and social we are saying that
people have to come first it is not the
files it is not the apps it's the people
that come first once i have created a
group of people i want to be able to do
everything with this group of people any
data I want to share any app that I want
to run I should be able to interact with
that same group of people I don't have
to go to Facebook go through app and I
log in facebook Lynette one after the
other and by the way do you know that if
I just go and play for example a
scrabble game on facebook connect with
like few when I do Facebook Connect they
see all my 1000 friends why well why not
I suppose from their perspective but
that's how things are built in the past
and that's what I suppose computer
science people trying to do is to say
this is not how we need to build things
so for us the group's come in first and
we build on Tom this architecture the
OpenSocial mobile architecture which I
was well I talked about before we're at
the core is just a messenger oh by the
way
you know how to say that word osm yeah
it's awesome alright so we do groups
first and groups become the first class
object it is something that lifts on
your phone and you can apply it to any
app everywhere on your phone and our our
mission is to make every single app of
your phone social and let me just
illustrate them with use case you use
case examples so what I did with you
just now is that I am sharing pictures
with you instantly and collaboratively
so this is the front screen it is got a
bunch of chats I mean I suppose you've
seen something like that before each is
a group so maybe the first one is a
dinner party that I'm at I may be with
an individual I may be happy in a group
and so forth and I these are the groups
and then each one of them will have a
lock of all the things that people right
and if I want to share this with a group
I click one button I invite people
nearby and what does it say it says I
share openly or which is what i just did
because i'm at the university or i can
also protect it with a pen when you
click that i get the pin number I tell
you it's 1234 then you and I can
exchange on the spot without other
people looking at the data and so right
on the spot then the information shows
up if you guys download the app you will
see the under nearby I have an etl group
you click on it we are sharing right
away so after you create a group you can
add email messages to shoot you can add
individuals to the group just like you
do email messages we want to make group
formation as fast as writing a bunch of
email and you know how it is right once
you have a bunch of people in the group
and you can reuse this over and over
again and some example and in in some
some of these groups you just sent one
message and it's over but some of these
you like you know you use more and then
they just become persistent so it is
very very easy to
create groups and what is interesting is
that so suppose we are here at a party
and we are taking pictures of each other
I take a picture you take a picture and
for me to take a picture is very simple
I click this button you get a set of
apps that are relevant to this context
and say I click camera I take a picture
when I finish the king the picture it
goes straight into that group ok so it's
automatic that it is shared with that
group it is cut contextual sharing I
don't have to take a picture upload it
and say this is shared with these five
people because by the virtue of me
clicking this button inside this group I
already specify what I want to share and
these are apps that you may want to use
with the group and we have done in such
a way that some of these app for example
camera plus is a third-party app all
right so you can just say here are all
the other apps that are compatible and
give you can just use it with your
friends so what we found is that when
your apps are contextual they get used a
little bit more often ok it is like it's
like if I want to so for example here is
a blackjack game and say oh maybe I want
to share I play a game with these guys I
want to interact with them the point is
not to play the game the point is to
interact with them and these are just
things that I can just activities I can
interact with them boots so once you get
the pictures so what we have also made
possible is that the corner there is
that if you click the button of that
corner then it flips over it becomes a
photo album alright so now you actually
have a joint photo album that you can
you are creating at the same time you
don't have to wait for upload download
and the model is like you go to a party
everybody takes like five pictures you
get 200 pictures and then you pick the
ones that you want you save it into your
gallery and after pictures that you know
of yourself usually and people that you
like and that's how you can share so
what we are doing here is that you
create these join folders but
this group and sharing purposes from a
computer science perspective this chat
is nothing but a transaction log of
database updates and when I send you a
picture by the way I'm giving you a
thumbnail but it can point to the large
high-definition picture or video that i
have in my backup service and now we are
sharing data straight up from our our
backup services and now we can choose
which one we want to use so that's an
example of a collaborative collection of
data what about collaboration I set
collaboration remember so here's an
example somebody sent me a picture and
maybe I just want to say congratulations
and and put up a meme and i want to send
it back so how does how do we do this in
this model so here here is a picture I
click this button the button opens up
and it says oh I click the picture the
picture opens up and here are all the
things that I can do remember the
group's come first it's not the apps
that come first you given this picture
all these apps are meaningful to so the
apps show up so I can use a filter i can
put a sticker on i can put a meanwhile i
can do whatever i don't have to go to
the gallery back and forth now i can do
a whole bunch of things at the same time
and when i am done with the with
decorating this picture i say finish and
then it is shared right back okay so
everything is all people first and we're
just interacting with each other using
all the apps we have on that'll give you
another example suppose we want to play
a game here so this is so so so I say
look I want to play a game with TJ and I
click on this button and it says oh here
are all the things that we do you see
that deserves a change in you I hear
this is our University version this is
on Android and hear all the things I can
do now I want to walk through this and
and show you some of the examples here
the first the third one is called eat
bento what is e Pinto
event well we have a Japanese visitor
and when they say Yvette they say II
Beth and so II bentyl is kind of like
evite for events get it anyway so this
is a quickie way of doing evite but this
eat bento is very different from evite
because you click on it you set up the
invite and it just goes to your friends
there is no third party that holds all
the email addresses and do whatever they
wish with it it just happens it is
really quick really easy to write as
well that app building a scalable evite
is not so quick another example is
slight mental this is the webex
basically here are my slides I put it
into my list and if you are not able to
be here I put your name in like an email
address and you see me and then you can
pick up the same slides and as I run
through the slide one by one you know is
great for tablets then remotely the
slides also move with it and this is all
just done in a distributed way you don't
have to create a whole new company I
mean a whole company just to collect
everybody slides and distribute them for
four people so it just completely
changes this is a distributed model of
things so in this case suppose I want to
click the button wordplay this is the
scrapple game how does it look like I
say a scrabble game it shows up on my
screen it shows that by my friend screen
and my friend may not have even
downloaded the game but in our case we
can go ahead and click the button and we
can play the game and we finished
playing the word and my friend then go
downloads the code because I got an
invite and I have already been playing
this game and then he download the game
and then when he finished downloading
the game he realized that i'm already in
motion you know i'm already in you know
playing this game and then they click
they continued so this is what i was
referring to about human
synchronizations i can get started with
a multi-party interaction
even right before my friend has download
the software and the reason why you're
able to do that is that the group is the
first class object we pass that around
and this is how you can just eliminate
the human synchronizations and the
effect of this is very useful for app
creators because now the app can spread
through friends before having this
overhead of asking friends to download
this code so this is an something that
is interesting to app creators because
spreading the gains is probably the most
the hardest thing on earth another
example this is an integration with
pulse that we did here is an example
where here is a story do you have any
people here in no pulse so you subscribe
to these new stories and one thing with
the integration you can now subscribe to
a social feet the social story these are
all the stories that my friends share
with me I don't have time to read all
the other channels are also many
channels but my friends may run into
some things that they want to share with
me and sharing new stories is one of
those things that often times you really
don't want to broadcast it because it is
very specific to the interest of the
individuals you know it is not exactly
for the sake of privacy necessary but it
is just I don't want to spam everybody
with something that I know only one
third of my friends care about so now
you can say oh this is a story I want
you click and then you choose the quick
and then it just shows up on the other
side all the messages Jing is done by
the messaging system and in that way
Paul's can get the social function done
with within like an afternoon okay
because they don't have to put up the
social function they don't have to put
up the messaging and they don't have to
put up the servers so this is a totally
different way of separating social from
the apps the app creators can just focus
on the apps and then the social can be
taken care of very very easily so what
we're creating here is a platform that
gives something you know it's a it's a
two-sided platform
on one hand you have users on the other
hand we have the apt developers for the
users they say look this is frictionless
multi-party interactions I like the fact
that my friends are not i'm just not
spreading my friend's email addresses
all over the place and at the same time
from an app developers this is oh great
i can take my solo app i can add social
to it in a couple of hours I don't have
to stand up a servers and I get social
functions and at the same time because
the apps are placed in these contextual
groups they get used more often you know
it's like a lot of times I download an
app I look at it and and I've done with
it but now it reminds me to is like oh
your friend is playing this game is that
okay I'll play that game too or you know
there's just a lot more interactive
games that can happen with this model
and finally the ability to spread across
the France before they even download
again because I can start playing even
before my friend has downloaded the game
it's something that helps people play
with these multi-party collaborative
apps so this is a very different model
of how we build social compared to the
old way and with that it also brings
about a different kind of company so the
company that we're doing will be social
Inc is really a new breed of companies
where we say we are not here with the
agenda to steal your data okay we just
want to facilitate a new open way of
doing social and and if you know the you
know it is not interesting to us we have
made the architecture low-cost enough
that you know because we're just sending
the messages around we're not holding
the data forever we don't have to build
these very expensive data centers and
therefore we can recoup hours our
expenses in a very different way than
the companies that focus on hoarding
users data and the goal here is to
really build and leverage an awesome
community the open social mobile
community and the pea
you know deep in there are all kinds of
potential partners from individuals
schools who don't want to give the
students a way of interacting without
worrying about privacy concerns
companies app developers it's a simpler
way to do social potentially reaching a
lot more people because it is on the
phone it is also great for cloud service
providers because now they can
participate in providing data there are
lots of cloud services out there these
days they can they can all compete to
provide this open social networking
model device manufacturers carriers and
so forth anybody who is interested who
it has a strategic interest to see a
more open environment would be a good
partner for us and we believe that with
this open competition it will fulfill
the promise of mobile which means that
you can free to socialize with anybody
and I think what will happen because
that is that you would generate a lot
more apps there are a lot of apps that
have to do with that are too small to
turn into a app company there are a lot
of micro interactions that are made
possible this is better for education
there are things like finance fitness
those things don't go too well on these
public social proprietary social
networks so that's what we're up to and
we you know one thing that we said was
that with this model is really easy to
build social games or social
interactions so how easy is it so last
summer we have seven high school
students working with us and this is the
meego high school project and with
between the seven of them in six weeks
they built five multi-party games all
right and they didn't know they have but
they all had one class of computer
science before they have never to have
never seen html5 we taught them whatever
it takes actually they learn a lot of
themself and we got them building these
games themselves so here are some
examples of it bucketlist truth or dare
and that's a funny
game portal allows you to check into
games to say to tell your friend that
I've already checked into the Xbox
please come and play crossword puzzle
that allows you to actually helps you
review your your class material the last
one is actually particularly interesting
it's the nose game what's the nose game
who has a go by coca-cola me by coffee
and the last one you have to go buy
coffee can you imagine building an app
to do that can you imagine and it was
like oh I want to play the close game
could you first download that game all
right you finished downloading the game
all right I'm ready to play that doesn't
work that's a micro interaction in this
particular case the groups are set up
there chatting with each other and all
we are doing here is a little html5 web
page that you just send around everybody
touches the nose games over alright so
this is the kind of thing that we can do
as a result of our totally different way
of building things so I would say that
knows game is is like the best example
of an AF ap app and and I I mean I would
never have come up with that idea i can
tell you that do you know why by the way
all these games other students came up
with them and that is because i found
out that the high school students they
are really experts in wasting time and
so they came up with things i would
never have come up with anyway so what
we're seeing here is programming
simplicity from the multi-party games
you can run it on the two plus chat just
like web pages are run on web browser it
will open up a lot more multi-party
social apps and just one more thing that
I want to bring up is that while we are
working with the high school students we
discovered something that is very
horrifying for the cs professors because
they were telling me what CS people look
like they think they are not created
solitary CSS tedious no impact exclusive
nerdy and there's a lot of a lot of high
school really want high school students
again the computer science but somehow
we have a very bad stereotype and so by
the way the high school students had a
great experience because we allow them
to be creative and as a result we
actually started another start at the
program to say maybe for us to get high
school students into the program we
really have to break the stereotype tell
them that computer science is actually
really creative that's why I'm in
computer science and so what we're doing
is running a video competition to start
and getting the high school students
thinking about things they want to build
and we think that if they figure out
things that they want to build and we
show them it is actually quite doable
then maybe they will they will go take
more computer science classes so that
was another project that we are that
there was kind of like a spinoff from
the work that we have done so let me
just summarize here is that what we're
talking about is a different way of
building social and mobile the awesome
way of building it and it is kind of
like a new social 2 point 0 is what I
think where it is a phone based social
Internet you don't have to belong to an
environment each to a proprietary
network each time you get to be free to
socialize with anybody and I invite
everybody here is a joined us awesome
community and I truly believe that open
competition rules I don't know if some
of you might remember AOL and and AOL is
a very proprietary system before and
when you have something open it is
really hard to compete against all right
I think that so that leaves us a few
minutes for discussions and maybe I'll
just open it up to the audience so Tina
ok I'm allergic so your professor and
a co-founder these companies what can
role do you play and how much time do
you spend on these ventures relative to
the amount of time you spend you know
teaching and doing research at Stanford
oh so the question is how do you combine
teaching and research with
entrepreneurship so it's a standard
system that universities let professors
get take sabbaticals every seven years
and you get at Stanford you get at most
two you can be off campus two years out
of seven so it so happened that way by
the way I did not try to you know do all
the researchers to start a company we
worked on some of the hardest problems
and it so happened that after some
number of years in this case five years
my students wanted to start a company
and I was able to because my you know I
I can take a sabbatical leave and at
that point I can really work full time
with the students for a couple of years
and the interesting thing is that you
learned so much when you leave an
academic environment to do something
different and you learn different sets
of skills and different kind of
interests and I think it is a really
good system because every time I come
back from a sabbatical I have new ideas
that i really want to pursue yes your
first spin up over the lessons learned
from that time then your corporate now
into this new staff oh very interesting
question the kind of spin know that I do
are not the ones that I necessarily
recommend to everybody here because we
started these projects as computer
science research projects and they are
usually very disruptive and so the first
company tries to correct what we did is
that we let people have custom process
of course in a sec chips so it's a great
idea but it takes a while because it is
so disruptive and by the way this is 10
circa they just they just sold the
company to Cannes
and it's successful but it takes a while
what in the second company was company
called mocha 5 where we look at use
where we use virtual technology virtual
memory virtual machine technology for
computer management and it's a huge
problem again and it is very disruptive
and it also takes time and if I look at
what happened in those two times is like
in research we try to solve the problem
in the optimal way but the minute you
leave the university you find that
nobody is ready to absorb what you are
trying to reach so you have this
go-to-market issue and that is that the
first thing you have to do is to tick
where you're going and reduce it down to
these bite-sized pieces something that
they can possibly absorb and then you
build your way back up so the work that
we did kind of in the university is kind
of like research for the next 7 15 years
depending how you look at it and then
you kind of work your way back up and we
were we were lucky because I think the
problems we solve our seared are real
serious ones they don't they're not the
fickle ones they don't change and even
though we take such a heavy-handed
approach to them it's it student the
time of the test of time we have the
time to keep working and then it it will
come in after a while because we were
looking up because we were focusing on
the trends so for example in this one
we're focusing on the trends that there
will be a lot of distributed computing
and this will be the right architecture
as a result of that I don't know when
this is going to come in but it is true
that in the last three experiences it's
getting faster and faster but there is a
very interesting relationship between
university research projects and ends
and startups as a result of that
business brother master how this is
going to for me to the market
it seemed like something that you would
do in collaboration with either phone
manufacturer phone companies or the
networks themselves what I can see I can
imagine it being a nap right now and I
yes axis accesses other apps what's the
you have some sense of a how it's all
possible and again it goes oh the
question is how is this gonna go to
market I mean is it going to be an
over-the-top app or it's going to be a
partnership with with with device
manufacturers or carriers and they are
all possibilities I mean we are very
early at this stage and we there is a
lot of interest because the problem is
so big there are a lot of strategic
interest in this space and iverson alee
think that the there there should be
enough players that wants an open system
you know I mean of course there are a
lot of very very large companies wanting
to own the space but at the same time
there's still a lot of large companies
out out out of those competing companies
that would like to see an open system
and hopefully something like this may
would happen what do you guys think is
there a chance would you would you would
you be interested in using something
like this yeah really i mean i would use
it like at a big conference or like at a
concert we give people sharing like
you're nearby photos and stuff so one
thing we want to do is to see if the
dorms will use it for communication
between people in the dorms just you
know there are so many things happening
in the dorms and they just keep each
other up to date of the things and then
it's like one of my one of some of the
students were telling me is like I don't
want to friend all my dorm mates and on
facebook I don't want to unfriend them
and so here's just an example there was
a need for coordination and here's just
one way of making that happen well if
you guys can use it that will do it for
us actually
wait I think that's one of the most
important things I think there is a
question of it there ahead just fo V the
technology that how much does this
require in terms of actual phone
resources like battery and processor and
stuff like that it's um I think the
question is the resources on the
computers the biggest difference that
you should note is that this is a push
based network so far as opposed to a
poll based in the Facebook world is like
gazillion people are talking and then
you will you you see a fraction of
whatever first of all what Facebook
feeds to you and at the same time what
you pull all right but here is for more
of a genuine network where you are
sending people sending things to the
people that you think they want to read
and as long as you are reading them then
there's not that much of a difference
between Facebook and this in terms of
resources because you still have to read
them all right but it is true that there
is a lot of data that is that you are
not fetching if you don't want to read
it on facebook because that's a
different model all right um over there
and we ever stinking same behind so if
you want to talk to me you can do that
you know mobile technologies is is there
a limit on which you know when people
just because people's obviously still
appreciate your face to face
interactions so you know isn't there an
interesting limit to what mobile
technology can do to our central lives
or you think it's gonna replace dinners
or whatever coffee chance so what is the
role of mobile and does it replace
physical interactions no it doesn't I
mean that the use of collaborative
software has existed from the beginning
of time on on you know pcs if you
imagine the following these are phones
think about the tablets we are getting
to a point where people were kids off
nothing but tablets are not the pcs
basically every piece of software that
you have I mean you you will be seeing
them on these mobile devices and there
is just need for collaboration we work
together we
bill we make a video together we do
things together and if you are new if
you need a device you want to do if you
need software you want to do it socially
that's how I would think about how big
social is there is introductions with
dr. doctors teachers all this is like a
group of people making a trip to a
conference everything is social so we're
social animals so I think that is fake
but it does not replace physical of
course on behalf of basis dfj and
chamber Technology Ventures program I
like to thank you professor lamb for
coming out and giving your wonderful
talk to oh thank you thank you
you